[Music]
we continue our ongoing series a more
perfect union this morning to show us
how what unites us as Americans is far
greater than what divides us today we
look at the power of body language
written in ink more than 50 million
Americans have at least one tattoo
many get inked to celebrate a memory or
a loved one Tony de copal has a story of
second chances when Ana tattoos meaning
is something the owner would rather
forget Tony good morning good morning
whether in prison or out there on the
streets for some a gang tattoo or a
symbol of hate can seem at least for a
moment like a great idea but long after
those people move on in their hearts the
tattoos can make it impossible to move
on in their lives now one tattoo parlor
in Baltimore has decided to help by
using pigments to make a positive change
are you ready for this buddy yeah Randy
Sturgill knows a lot about getting
tattoos the 28 year old has them all
over his body most he got while serving
eight years in prison for armed robbery
but today isn't about new ink it's about
becoming a new man let me see your hand
and basically what that is is a Nazi
death head is out it is yes the same
emmalin's belzoni Nazi officer helmet
why did you get it you know it sounds
really stupid but I mean I did it I
guess kind of fit in yeah if you've made
that mistake in your past that in your
life we're gonna help you out one day
each week
shop owners Elizabeth and Dave cut lip
cover up racist and gang-related tattoos
for free we had someone come in here
that had tattoos on their face of the
gang that they were in in prison we
referred him to get laser treatment and
on the way home I said to Dave you can
probably help a lot of people they you
know cover up these gang tattoos so they
could get jobs and reenter society and
not have that stigma attached to
Oh typically a cover-up can run anywhere
from a few hundred to well more than a
thousand dollars and the cut lips aren't
only comping local customers in January
they made their offer to the whole world
we posted it on Facebook that we were
going to help people thinking that we
were just going to help people in our
community and I just see the numbers
like they're going up to thousands and
thousands and thousands and then
messages started pouring in and pouring
in and pouring in it's the other ones
we're gonna start working on yeah it's
exactly what you think it is it's us
it's a southern pride with a noose
inside the Confederate flag with almost
5,000 cover-up requests so far the
couple launched a website the goal is to
build a national network of tattoo
parlors where customers can kick start a
new life by covering the hateful symbols
of their old one I didn't know there
were that many racist people in America
sometimes I would read these emails and
I would cry and I'm just like I cannot I
cannot believe like that they had that
much hate inside of them how do you know
they don't still have it inside of them
I would like to think that I'm a pretty
good judge of character and I know that
she is and and we we definitely talk to
these people and you can see it if
they're you know if they're changed time
you feel good the cut lips say they use
social media to check the background of
potential customers like Randy if they
sense the client isn't genuinely ready
to change
they won't do the tattoo what would you
say to somebody who thinks that you can
cover up the hateful image but you can't
change the man you know I guess there
comes town everybody's life when you
change whether you're dead or alive has
that time come for you yeah it's
definitely kinda the guy who walked in
that first day with the tattoos on his
face I wish I knew a thing but he had
tears in his eye that kind of shook me
up you do still kind of tear up when you
talk about this why does it affect you
so much um
I think I think it's important that
everybody gets a second chance that's
pretty much covered up me and in the
bottom line is no more nazi death skull
we're done right and four tattoos that
are two prominent to simply cover up the
cut lips are hoping to use the almost
$20,000 they've raised on a GoFundMe
page to pay for laser tattoo removal and
they have a message for the man with the
face tattoo that inspired their whole
project if you're watching come back in
they'll remove it for free they've got
the money for it now how many people
actually get their tattoos I love that
the cut lips are doing this though to to
get rid of hateful messages how often do
people actually get rid of they're very
very few so this is not in the piece but
fifty million Americans have a tattoo
fewer than a hundred thousand per year
get their tattoo removed so apparently
most people feel they made a good
decision
are you can we are thinking about your
[ __ ] stamp
I was wondering you thought about stage
now now you know where to go trap
station yes it's right here right I
don't think it's a charity for that
removal yet okay I'm gonna keep my
mother screaming big television right
now baby sir he hasn't seen it it's a I
don't have my Donald it's a joke it's a
joke Tony thank you thank you